à 9 ans la petite ariel est heureuse de
pouvoir lever le voile sur les
menstruations avec sa maman lors de cet
atelier
elle n'aura pas honte d'en parler quand
ces règles viendront ariel souhaite que
plus de jeunes filles se sentiront comme
elle
la maman d'ariel elle a dû faire cet
apprentissage seul stigmatisation
menstruel et silence honteux ont
longtemps accompagné les règles
l'organisme whitbread organise ces
ateliers dans son musée sur les
menstruations afin de briser les tabous
entourant la santé menstruel dans le
système scolaire taïwanais le sujet est
souvent vu en vitesse l'organisme
whitbread mais il est aussi pour
l'équité monstrueuse c'est à dire
favoriser l'accès aux produits d'hygiène
féminine à celles qui sont moins
fortunés et qui en ont le plus besoin le
problème est criant dans plusieurs pays
d'asie
selon les données recueillies par
wilfred et sa jeune fondatrice de 24 ans
vivent ils in une femme sur dix à taïwan
n'auraient pas accès à des produits
hygiéniques
quand elle en a besoin à
16,9
à
ottawa le gouvernement allouera 25
millions de dollars pour combattre
l'iniquité monstrueux l ou canada
souvent liées à la pauvreté
le
dvd est venu à l'atelier sur la santé et
lee quitté menstruel avec ses jumelles
de 10 ans
il croit que les hommes aussi doivent en
savoir plus court osé en parler sophie
et doha elles pourront discuter ensemble
de ce qu'elles viennent d'apprendre
partager ses expériences de toutes
sortes avec sa soeur sans gêne ça n'a
pas de prix ici philippe leblanc radio
canada taipei